وفي اول تعليق له على حادث نوتينغهام وصف
رئيس الوزراء البريطانيك هذا الحادث
بالصادم وقال انه على اطلاع دائما على
تطورات الوضع وانه يجب اعطاء الشرطه الوقت
الكافيه للقيام بعملها سوناك تنوها في
تغريده له بسرعه استجابه الشرطه وخدمات
الطوارئ لهذا الحادث الذي وقع صباح اليوم
من جديد معنا من لندن مراسلتنا من حربلو
من نتابعك وانت
تتابعين اخر المستجدات المرتبطه بهذه
الحوادث ما الذي قراته عنها
نعم يعني هناك بعض من
من عناصر الشرطه البريطانيه السابقين
الذين تعاملوا مع مثل هذه الحوادث يقولون
بان بين يدي شرطه نوتينغام مهمه كبيره
للتوصل لما حدث او معرفه حقيقه ما حدث
وتحديد
الدوافع وراء هذه العمليات المتتاليه التي
اعلنت الشرطه عن اعتقال الشخص يبلغ من 31
من العمر
لاشتباه في في انه قام بقتل
نفذ عمليه القتل يعني بعد العثور على
ثلاثه اشخاص قتلى اثنان منهم يعني في
منطقه وسط في شارع
واحد اخر في شارع اخر وسط المدينه ثم بعد
ذلك عمليه محاوله
الاشخاص ثلاثه هم الان يتلقون العلاج في
المستشفى رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسوناك قال بانه يجب اعطاء الشرطه
الوقت الكافي للوقوف على ما حدث وتحديد
الدوافع وحيثيات هذه العمليه وقال بانه
بانه يتم اطلاعه على تطورات هذه العمليه
من ناحيه اخرى شرطه
نشرت بلاغا قالت فيه بان على الناس ان
الصبر يعني اوسط حتى الناس على الصبر
ومنحها الوقت من اجل اتمام هذه التحقيقات
التي قالت انها تحقيقات لا تزال في
بداياتها بعد اعتقال هذا الشخص والعثور
على القتلى الثلاثه والمصابين الثلاثه
قالت بان بعض الطرق ستظل مغلقه حتى
الانتهاء من هذه التحقيقات هذه
التي اعتبرتها الشرطه شرطه في بدايتها
بانها حادث خطير قالت بانها تتعامل معه
بعد تلبيه يعني خدمات الطوارئ من ثلاث من
يعني سواء من الاسعاف والاطفاء والشرطه
للحضور في بعض الابلاغ عن اول عمليه في
الساعه الرابعه من هذا الصباح هذه نعم
سنكون معك لاحقا لمزيد من المعلومات من
الحربلو من لندن شكرا جزيلا